what tub's not really my thing what is
your thing then
complex female characters
complex female characters are my thing
too
but actually i think all females are
complex
and non-females too
humans are complex we have memory we can
think and we age
but why do any of these things happen
and do we become more or less complex
with age
and can understanding complexity and
modeling it with approaches from systems
biology finally help us understand why
we age and how we can stay healthy for
longer
well let's discuss
i thought we'd begin with this paper i
put in a thumbnail loss of complexity
and aging by lewis lipsetts
this paper came out in 1992
so in my reference it's an old paper
but this is still very relevant for
today
take a look at this first figure
it shows on the upper panel the normal
sinus rhythm heartbeat at rest in a
healthy 22 year old female subject
the bottom panel is for a 73 year old
man
the heart rate for both of them is 64
beats per minute
yet the plots look very different
the younger female plot looks more
chaotic
but to be fair so does the older one
just lasso
and that brings us back to the premise
behind this article
potential applications of fractals and
chaos theory due senescence senescence
here referring to aging more generally
not cellulose in essence my favorite
cell
process and so this paper essentially
describes how these mathematical
principles could be applied to create a
new framework to understand quantitate
and model aging
we won't go too much into the math
because partly because it was never
maths i was taught at university
and because it's not necessary to know
what the math means to understand what
it shows
it's kind of like a christopher nolan
movie
don't try to understand it
okay maybe it's not like a christopher
nolan movie
but the two concepts are fractals
irregular complex shapes that have
underlying patterns
and chaos
apparently unpredictable behavior that
can arise from internal feedback loops
of non-linear systems
a feature that seems to be apparent in
many biological networks
an example of the loss of anatomic
complexity of age shown in this paper is
that of neuronal dendrites
here the branching of the dendrites is a
measure of fractal-like complexity and
the age effect is a lot of dendrites and
reduced branching
now these anatomic and functional slash
physiological descriptions are all good
and well
but they don't really inform us much on
what is causing these changes to occur
two rationales are that complexity is
lost due to a lot of functional
components
and or altered non-linear coupling
between these components
but what components are we really
talking about here
well i mean this article came out in
1992 so after all zephalian's efforts
that i'm not gonna i'm not really gonna
criticize the paper
for not finding out what these
components are
because frankly a lot of things in the
biology world have happened since 1992
i was born
we sequenced the human genome we advance
technology and not just dna sequencing
but rna sequencing progemics chromatin
structures fancy microscopy techniques
data outputs from these methods can
range from thousands for gene expression
to many many more when it comes to
quantifying microscopy images
so we now have a lot of data and tools
that we can use to address these
questions
but how do we make sense of all the data
well this is the goal of computational
systems biology
systems biology can be used to explain
how complexity arises
i recently read the book a very short
introduction to systems biology by
eberhart floyd a professor in the
department of biomedical engineering
a good primer for anyone interested in
this field and i'm going to use an
example from the book to illustrate how
systems biology can help
some things can look complicated but
actually quite simple that is our brains
can understand it for example this rube
goldberg example looks complex but if we
just follow the linear series of events
we see that the movement of the man's
hand causes the napkin to be lifted
handy right
but alternatively simple things can be
very complex
let's start with an easy looking
biological system
let's say one with two components
a and b
imagining that a and b are both genes
and that they caved to proteins we can
see that when a is expressed its protein
product activates expression of itself
and also the expression of
gene b
and gene b when it's expressed inhibits
expression of a
so
if we begin with equal amount of a and b
what would happen in this case if a is
increased by 20 percent
well let's give some hypothetical
examples if we increase a we might
expect initially to see even higher
amounts of a because a can activate
itself
itself reinforces
but a is also activating b
and so we might then see a decline and
then as a declines there's less b
activation and so a increases and maybe
it sort of oscillates in a pattern
maybe this oscillation dies down or
maybe it goes on forever
or maybe we just see a increase and
reach a new steady state
or maybe a goes to zero maybe b goes to
zero the point is we don't know and
equate from the book
the answer to these questions is the
stabbing
only a mathematical model can provide
true answers
and it needs information on the
magnitudes of the production the
strengths of this activation and
inhibition and then this can be built
into the model
but let's say it did oscillate
what is then causing the oscillation if
neither component can oscillate without
the other
while this is said to be an emergent
feature
emergence can come then from seemingly
simple systems that display
unpredictable chaotic behaviors
systems biology can help us understand
them by formulating equations that
define the system
again from three apparently simple set
of equations which trust me although
they look
for non-mathematicians quite bad they
could be much worse
and if you start with different values
of x y and zed
you end up with very different
trajectories and some of them can end up
very complicated
now like with the heart rates we saw
earlier
you might be thinking why would
biological systems employ such chaotic
systems
well although the answer is not clear as
lewis lipstick states
it seems it can enable an individual to
adapt to the unpredictable changes of
everyday life
but to know for sure we really need to
quantitate it with information we can
understand
and so coming back now to aging can
systems biology be used to understand
health and disease in complex humans
well we've already seen a rise in a
number of consumer products more
recently from personalized genetic
testing microbiome testing sleep
trackers glucose monitors epigenetic
measures and maybe on their own they do
have some predictive value for disease
risk or health estimates
but one idea that struck me from reading
this short entry to systems biology was
the idea of simulators
now the classic example of simulators
you're probably aware of are flight
simulators used to train pilots or for a
fun family activity
these flight simulators such as that of
boeing 737 can contain up to 367 000
parts and it uses principles from
physics to model what happens under
different flight conditions
pretty impressive
but the human body has 40 trillion cells
and each of these cells has its own
molecular inventory of metabolites
proteins lipids you name it
and although research is actually being
conducted to try and build human
simulators such as the jump simulation
center at the university of illinois to
revolutionize medical education
but if we did have such a model for a
healthy human
we wouldn't really need that many
parameters and at least initially we
would reduce the number of parameters to
those physiological features involved in
the specific disease case of interest
and so for a healthy human they would
have parameter values within a normal
range
this normal range accounts for
interpersonal variations among healthy
individuals
sensitive parameters have small ranges
while insensitive parameters have larger
ranges
if we pick any two parameters the
product of the ranges is a rectangle
now if we assume that
extreme combinations are inconsistent
with health so you sort of truncate the
corners you end up with a polygon
and then if we add in all these other
parameters
we end up increasing the number of
dimensions of the polygon and higher
dimensions of polygons in mathematical
terms is known as a simplex
so foi refers to this as a health
simplex
which could also be thought of as a high
dimensional biomarker space
if you're within the health simplex
you're well healthy and outside of it
unhealthy or in some transitional
disease states
so it becomes nested
this is obviously a much lower dimension
than it would actually be but mainly for
visualization purposes
and so this health simplex is surrounded
by a larger simplex of transient
unhealthiness
which could include conditions like a
fifa dehydration
this simplex is then in turn surrounded
by a disease simplex
and then a morbidity simplex
so health and various to see states form
nested simplexes
some distances between the subsequent
simplexes may be short others may be
much longer
and these distances could indicate the
severity of a disease
and it could also be used to identify
more important parameters
or biomarkers that
provide more value or indication for a
disease risk
and so floyd first presented this health
simplex
in 2009 in this paper
and he stated even then that the actual
completion of the health simplex must be
expected to take a very long time
but the thing is even if the full
simplex will not be available for some
while it will be feasible much sooner to
con to construct lower dimensional
simplexes that focus on one particular
disease and assume biomarkers in all
other dimensions to be irrelevant or
within their normal ranges
i like the idea that we can think of
aging as therefore being a departure
from our health symbolics
iso simplexes with their quantitative
characterization of many
parameters
could be used to create personalized
health trajectories health risk profiles
that change with age and evaluate the
efficacy of different treatment options
but we still don't have these health
simplexes and it's also important to
consider they are still built with many
assumptions
and the body we know can compensate for
some changes and maybe a disease occurs
only when the body can't implement such
adjustments
which maybe we couldn't predict from the
model
and so in that case the whole simplex is
still very much a conceptual framework
but the framework could eventually
become a means of qualitatively or
quantitatively characterizing risk
profiles and suggest personalized
preemptive measures of disease avoidance
it would therefore be interesting to
know
what is the smallest number of
dimensions in a health simplex that
would enable us to actually define
health and what would be the best and
easiest measurements to make
i don't know the answer to these
questions but i do think this
understanding is pretty interesting
and definitely in my opinion seems to be
a good way to understand
what aging is
but that's just my perspective what is
yours and i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening